hey everybody welcome to the live stream
I was just trying to finish up a book
I'm reading whenever I am traveling I
try to minimize the number of books I
bring and I've got like 20 pages to go
in this book about the Rwandan genocide
that I'm reading and I don't want to
bring that to finish it before the plane
even takes off tomorrow and then I've
got to lug this book around the rest of
the trip doesn't seem efficient doesn't
seem doesn't seem like the right thing
to do so I'm gonna try to finish that up
tonight after the stream of course major
breaking news which is that special
prosecutor Robert Muller has been called
to testify before the house we're going
to get to all of the details and I'm
glad that you are joining me this is
going to be the last livestream for a
little bit because I do fly out tomorrow
to Las Vegas I'm meeting Sam cedar there
I think our flights actually get in
within a few minutes of each other oh we
will see if we end up sharing a ride to
the hotel and of course I can only
imagine that settlement negotiations
would take place in the car if we do end
up sharing a ride I will be broadcasting
from Las Vegas for the rest of the week
other than tomorrow tomorrow Ben Dixon
will be filling in for me on the
broadcast program which will be great he
hasn't filled in for a bit and I know
he's looking forward to it and he was
emailing me about stories and the plan
for tomorrow earlier today so that's all
great stuff happening tomorrow what else
is going on I may try to stream from Las
Vegas there were a bunch of requests for
me to stream Sam's streaming Sam cedar
from majority report who will also be
broadcasting from the conference sort of
like a Inception type of thing or
Russian dolls or whatever Sam will
stream and then I will stand like 30
feet from Sam and stream like a side
view of him streaming and then maybe
somebody would even stream that if if
we're lucky welcome to the stream if
this is your first live stream before we
get into it these are really live unless
they're replays last two streams there
was a lot of confusion people sending
super chats and signing up for
memberships after the stream ended
believing that it was live because it
was archived so it's live when it's live
and then it's replayed you can
communicate with me
using the super chat function at the
bottom of the chat window that's the
dollar sign we already got one super
chat and I will get to those in a little
bit if you have questions or comments
and you want me to read and react or
answer them that is the way to do it
please sign up for membership using the
coupon codes down below in the
descriptions if we get 10 new members I
will open up the phones
and if we get 15 I may even commit to
streaming from Las Vegas we'll see about
that don't troll the live chat trolling
the live chat will be extra difficult
starting today because we have two new
actually we have three new moderators
since two live streams ago and an
additional moderator since the live
stream so people are the bands are free
and I have fully deputized the
moderators to take advantage of them and
lastly you can also join by using the
join button down below we are part of a
youtube beta program called YouTube
channel membership we will count those
towards the target of 10 new members
during the stream and with that being
said let's get into this breaking news
story the House Judiciary Committee is
calling on Robert Muller to testify now
this is not yet a subpoena but I will
get to that momentarily House Judiciary
Chairman Jerrold Nadler
I shouldn't highlight that it makes it
more difficult to read joined ranking
member congressman doug collins a
Republican from Georgia in calling for
special counsel Robert Mulder to testify
before the committee after Congress
receives his full report and hears from
attorney general william bar now this is
news okay but there are already two
caveats here
Moeller should testify after Congress
gets his full report when will that be
we don't know and after Congress has her
heard from Attorney General William bar
when will we hear from william bar we
also don't know so this is significant
but there are still a number of steps
here that need to be accomplished before
this is going to happen we have a quote
here from Jerry Nadler today ranking
member Collins called for special
counsel molars who appeared before the
House Judiciary Committee I fully agree
special counsel molars should come
before the committee to answer questions
in public about his 22 month
investigation into President Trump and
his associates in order to ask special
counsel Moeller
the right questions the committee must
receive the special counsels full report
and hear from attorney general Barr
about that report on May 2nd we look
forward to hearing from mr. Muller at
the appropriate time so as you can see
two caveats and then there's a third
caveat which is that this is not a
subpoena at least at this point in time
it's a request it's a request which
Robert Muller until such time that he is
subpoenaed can either accept or deny and
then it would be up to the Judiciary
Committee to decide whether they want to
subpoena Robert Muller my guess is
Muller would appear as Axios goes on to
say the backdrop earlier on Monday
congressman Collins published a letter
criticizing Democrats attempt to
subpoena the unredacted report writing
on Twitter quote Democrats can cite no
precedent for their demands for grand
jury information from the hashtag Muller
report but there is a solution we should
all be able to agree on the Judiciary
Committee should invite the special
counsel to testify immediately Collins
said that molars should testify the week
of April 22nd the house is expected to
be on recess that week but Collins wrote
I think we can agree this business is
too important to wait and members of the
committee will surely return to
Washington at such a critical moment in
this country's history there's a funny
thing with those recesses I'm in touch
with a couple members of Congress and
everybody always is not desperate but
eager to get back to their home
districts or to go on vacation or to do
other things during those recess weeks
and until such time that they have some
pet project or something they believe
will get them publicity at which point
all of a sudden they say this is just
too important for us to be on break
let's cancel the recess let's be here we
see it in the Senate as well with votes
and filibusters and the entire thing and
generally speaking from what I'm told by
these members of Congress they there is
some resentment when you're looking
forward to being home and who knows who
says the panel needs to meet because we
have important witnesses to talk to all
the
I agree that talking to Robert molar
rises to the level of extraordinarily
important in this particular case the
big picture bar who is currently working
with molar to redact the four hundred
page report has agreed to testify before
the committee on May 2nd though
Democrats have called on him to appear
sooner Muller has not made any public
statements about the report or his plans
to testify but a public appearance
before Congress would be a must watch
political spectacle for those who have
closely followed the two-year
investigation we we've got to get both
of these individuals to testify sooner
than later and of course we need the
report if the report if nobody gets the
report if the house doesn't get the
report if they get it in an outrageously
or comically redacted form it's also
going to be pretty difficult to ask
serious and important questions of
William bar and of Robert molar the key
question that is starting to float now
is will molar end up needing to be
subpoenaed I don't think that he will I
I think that there there's no reason to
think listen there would be some degree
of hypocrisy if after all of the
frustration that I presume Muller and
his investigators experienced as a
result of people who don't want to talk
to him and them up to an including
President Donald Trump for Moeller now
to say I'm not going subpoena me my
lawyers will fight it or whatever it
wouldn't wouldn't make any sense and it
would be a double standard that I don't
think there's a lot of hypocrites right
now in government there's a lot of
hypocritical actors I have seen no
evidence that that's something Robert
Muller would try to do now this doesn't
tell us that if he is to testify it is
going to be the explosive bombs series
of bombshells that we might like a lot
of what is brought up may not be
discussed in that public setting and may
end up being relegated to a to a private
behind-closed-doors meeting so we don't
know that's what we know so far now in
the midst of it there is all sorts of
other chaos taking place in the Trump
administration in
a sort of growing desperation on a
number of issues including the Donald
Trump tax return fiasco we covered a
bunch of this although not this latest
news on the broadcast show today clips
from which we'll be publishing to
youtube over the next several hours
unless you remember in which case you
already have seen all of today's show
the request made by my former
congressman Richard Neal to the Treasury
Department to the IRS for the last six
years of Donald Trump's tax returns is
one that is going to be maybe the most
difficult for the Trump administration
to avoid acquiescing to and it's really
not the Trump administration but Trump's
Treasury Department that would
ultimately make this decision there is a
law from 1924 which allows any House or
Senate committee that has tax writing
privileges to also request the tax
returns of anybody that they want the
President or whoever is in play doesn't
get a chance to say yes or no it is very
difficult to go against these requests
although we may see them tested and now
you are seeing every form of desperation
including now Mick Mulvaney rewriting
history or attempting to rewrite history
in this particular case here as you know
in 2014 as this Vox article points out
Trump said that if he decides to run for
office I'll produce my tax returns
absolutely I would love to do that in
2015 months before launching his
presidential campaign Trump told
conservative radio host Hugh Hewitt that
quote I would release tax returns I have
no objection to certainly showing tax
returns Trump reiterated this during the
first presidential debate with Hillary
Clinton with that caveat saying I'm
under a routine audit and it'll be
released and as soon as the audit is
finished it will be released so of
course we have no evidence that Trump is
under audit Michael Cohen has asserted
that this is merely Trump something that
Donald Trump says and of course we know
that it's a lie Donald Trump has no
intention of releasing his tax
period so I hope that this does work
although I think it's important in the
same way that a year ago I said if
you're hoping for the molar probe to
uncover evidence of personal collusion
with vladimir putin on the behalf of
Donald Trump there's almost zero chance
of that in that same way I think that if
you're hoping for criminality to be
definitively exposed by Donald Trump's
tax returns I don't believe it's gonna
happen I think the most likely two
scenarios in terms of Trump attack
Trump's tax returns are number one he's
not nearly as wealthy as he claims to be
and he's an egomaniac
so that actually may be a reason why he
would do everything possible to avoid
those tax returns being released
possibility number two is that Donald
Trump maybe doesn't want it known how
little in taxes he pays in terms of a
percentage of his income although I'm
less sure about that because he has
previously said that he's smart to pay
as little in taxes as possible this is
what everybody does and he's right about
that and I think that it actually would
not really damage him with his base if
it was uncovered that he was paying some
pathetically low effective tax rate so I
think the most likely scenario is that
he is not as wealthy as he has claimed
to be he is not as wealthy as some of
these lists of billionaires have claimed
him to be on the basis of inflated
assets and holdings and real estate by
Donald Trump so I think the tax returns
should be released if only because this
is what every presidential candidate for
the last 40 years have done if only
because Trump doesn't want them to be
released but I don't actually think
there's any serious possibility that we
will see Trump's taxes and say here's
crimes that Donald Trump committed along
the same lines of chaos at the White
House Donald Trump is also removing the
United States Secret Service Director
Tex Owls
Alys I don't know how his last name is
pronounced is being removed from his
position according to multiple
administration officials to CNN
President Donald Trump instructed his
acting chief of staff Mick Mulvaney who
as I told you in the last
is now pretending Donald Trump never
promised to release his tax returns
Trump directed Mulvaney to fire owls
owls remains in his position as of now
but has been asked to leave he was told
two weeks ago there would be a
transition in leadership and he was
asked to stay until there was a
replacement Secret Service officials
have been caught by surprise with the
news and are only finding out through
CNN according to the source now there
was this story last week and I think
this is referenced here yeah here it is
a source familiar with the director said
his ouster was not related to the recent
scrutiny the Secret Service got after a
Chinese woman illegally entered the
president's mar-a-lago club carrying
Chinese passports and a flash drive
containing malware she had a number of
conflicting and sort of confused stories
about exactly what she was doing
clarifying that Trump could not be
happier with Secret Service following of
the mar-a-lago incident Secret Service
has done a fantastic job from day one
very happy with them Trump said during a
White House event when asked by
reporters about the Mara Lago trespasser
the Secret Service director reports
directly to the Secretary of Homeland
Security Kirsten Nielsen who resigned
yesterday we talked about that on the
broadcast show today the director
oversees the Secret Service's work on
both protection and investigations there
is a near systematic purge happening at
the nation's largest second largest
national security agency one senior
administration official says I won't
rehash the entire Kirsten Neilson thing
because we did a long segment about it
on today's broadcast show so complete
and total chaos and disarray in the
Trump administration which has been one
of the themes or hallmarks of the last
couple of years and there is no
indication that it is going to slow down
anytime soon and I believe that Ben
Dixon will be covering some of that
tomorrow when he fills in for me as I
will be making my way to not sunny it's
actually cloudy right now cloudy Las
Vegas not nearly as hot as it normally
is but there will still be a very
very exciting progressive media meeting
of the minds which I will be telling you
about before you know it okay I want to
get to a bunch of the super chats that
are coming in but I'll remind everybody
who's just making their way and this is
a live stream unless it's a replay if
it's 7:15 p.m. Eastern on April 8th of
2019 I guess I should say if you don't
know what year it is you probably maybe
you're not here I don't know maybe there
are people watching who don't know what
your it is but I assume everybody knows
this is live unless it's a replay the
best way to communicate with me which
you can do much more easily than leaving
angry comments on uploaded videos is to
use the super chat function at the
bottom of the chat window
that's the dollar symbol it will pop up
your questions and comments on the
screen as you will see momentarily I
will address comments react to them and
also answer questions if you have them
please sign up for memberships on our
website if you want me to open the phone
lines ok I am willing to open the phone
lines particularly since this is likely
to be the last livestream of this sort
for a little while since I will be
traveling if we get to 10 new members I
will do it the phone line system costs
us money in March I did a record number
of live streams took a record number of
phone calls and correspondingly we had a
record-high phone ville which is why we
usually have some kind of new member
target there are two coupon codes
available which will save you just a ton
of money off of your membership one
coupon code is this is 2020 this
information is in the description down
below by the way the coupon code this is
2020 saves you 40% off of any membership
ok if you want to get an even bigger
discount on a percentage basis there is
a coupon code save 35 which will drop a
$60 membership to just 25 bucks if you
can afford two dollars in 8 cents a
month which is what that breaks down to
and you like the work that we do I'm
asking for your support and as a special
incentive if you are one of the 10
members new members that gets us to open
the phones I will take your phone call
first sim
include your area code when you sign up
in either the first or last name field I
will see it and then on that basis if we
open up the phone lines we will go to
you first so anybody who includes their
area code when they sign up I will go to
you before anybody else lastly don't
troll the live chat we have more
moderators than ever
overseeing the live chat and you can
also use the join button on YouTube
right down below we will count those
towards the target of ten okay let me
get to some of these super chats that
are coming in
Rober Xavier Betancourt jr. sent a $2.00
super chat right before we got going
with no question or comment but I still
appreciate it Robert thank you very much
Jason Zaremba sent a $4 $0.99 super chat
saying as a break from politics what are
your favorite movies also as a drummer
if you haven't seen whiplash you totally
should you know there are just so many
good movies I couldn't tell you what my
favorites are it's sort of like what's
your favorite book I there's just so
many I really couldn't say trying to
think what I've seen recently that I
liked I saw in Bruges recently which is
not new with Colin Farrell and it was
really great and I was recently in
Bruges Belgium and I saw the movie after
visiting and it was great but not super
exciting I don't watch that many new
movies and yeah I don't know as a
drummer if you haven't seen whiplash you
totally should I have not seen whiplash
and I know that I should and maybe maybe
it'll be available on my flight tomorrow
and I'll be able to watch it there was a
dollar super chat where the message was
retracted all right Sam Dean with the
ten Australian dollar super chat says a
friend said that it's good that the EPA
is going away says they shut down farms
that had e.coli and now e.coli ridden
food comes from Mexico is there any
validity to this or is my friend an
idiot I've not heard anything about the
EPA getting shut down let me see if I
can look that up
EPA shut down let's see here
not seeing anything like that yeah I
don't know what your friend is talking
about but I would Google that maybe
because I don't know where where they
got that information okay let's see who
else is here a whole bunch of different
super chats just came in Joseph din zis
is a new member using the join button
down below that is new member number one
for the evening one out of ten we're
well on our way
Joey techtalks says what are your
thoughts on ranked choice voting I think
it would be better for our country
overall other are there any downsides
there are some methods of rank choice
voting that have the downside that you
can end up with a person a candidate
winning without having been anyone's
first choice but there are methods that
solve that problem there's a bunch of
videos on our youtube channel addressing
that I do like elements of ranked choice
voting and I also recognize that there
are some shortcomings but I you know I
think the really the problem we have is
with the electoral college and there are
a number of ways that votes could be
counted at the state level all of which
could be good contenders but electoral
college at the federal level at the
national level I think is a much bigger
problem
Sabrina Zafar says thoughts on liberal
philosopher I never know how to say his
name
Slovo syczyk yeah I don't know exactly
how to say his name
my dad has read like everything by him
and could tell you anything you want to
know I think he's a fascinating guy his
demeanor of which is quite manic kind of
makes me nervous when I watch his videos
but we're actually we've been trying to
get him on the program and I hope to be
able to announce something related to
that
sooner than later another dollar super
chap that was retracted Brian Walters
would the new high super chat of the
evening at $30 just supporting you thank
you thank you Brian really appreciate
that extraordinarily generous and on
that note I want to thank two other
people
Joshua Stoltenberg has signed up for a
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership using the 40% off coupon code
this is 20 20 that is new member number
2 of the evening and you know what
arianna
became a patron just a few minutes ago
for 2 bucks a month at patreon.com slash
david pakman show even though I didn't
mention patreon
I'm an accountant I'm an accountant and
that actually gets us to 3 new members
we're looking for 10 and when we get to
10 I will open up the phone lines it's
always exciting to see if people start
leaving voice as soon as I go live even
though we haven't opened the phone lines
people start leaving voicemails yeah and
they're coming in like crazy the phone
lines aren't open yet if and when they
open the number will be 6 1 7 8 3 0 47
50 but we are seven new members away a
Joseph Dinsey says just signed up my
area code is 425 oh I get ok I guess
when I said Joshua Stoltenberg I guess
that that's Joseph dins 'yes now I'm
confused maybe I outed Joseph with a
different name than he wants to use but
I will make a note area code for 25 if
the phone lines open we will go to area
code 425 first now Joseph may just be
lying that that would be fascinating if
he just claims to have signed up and now
he's gonna get on the phones first let's
not make it a habit of just shouting out
area codes why don't we tied well says
kolinsky versus cedar in a cage match
who wins that's interesting I mean
listen Sam's in his early 50s and Kyle
is I don't know how old Kyle is he must
be close to my age in his early early to
mid 30s I think it's probably Kyle
although you know Sam I've seen Sam lick
the grand piano over his head and he's
much stronger than he looks so I don't I
don't know I also think it depends on a
time of day because being familiar with
Sam's schedule and Kyle's schedule
depending on when in the day this cage
match happened
that could be a pretty big factor blue
no we're $9.99 with a five Australian
dollar super chat says is there any way
you know of which Trump can prevent
Putin Trump can prevent Muller from
testifying
Freud Freudian slip there or releasing
his tax returns
put your anti-trump bias ease aside well
I mean listen I don't know of any legal
means through which Trump can prevent
Moeller from testifying Trump could try
to assert by the way why this is just a
legal question it's not a question of
bias Trump could try to assert executive
privilege in some way but I don't really
know how because Trump's communications
with Moeller in writing via his
attorneys were testimony so I don't know
if you could assert executive privilege
on that specifically and I don't know
the answer to the tax return question as
I mentioned earlier congressman Richard
Neal has requested six years of Donald
Trump's tax returns on the basis of a
1924 law that allows any tax writing
committees to do that we're going to see
it tested potentially I don't know if
there is a means for Donald Trump to
prevent that from happening
December with a to Canadian dollar super
chat David Pakman equals amazin well
thank you very much Jimmy from Philly oh
dear
Jimmy from Philly says hard bastard
eviscerated you on a video quote
analyzing David Pakman ridiculous molar
investigation coverage what say you
Capital capital why on you the walls are
closing in haven't seen it don't care
every day there is fifteen to twenty
videos of someone trying to make a buck
criticizing me don't care too busy with
my show don't don't have the time to
watch it
Matthew Campos is a new member on
YouTube that is new member number four
of the evening very much appreciated
just remember I say this with peace and
love when you're a Youtube member
YouTube keeps 30% of that if you sign up
on my website we get all but two point
nine percent there's a two point nine
percent payment fee we get the rest so
I'm just saying we keep a lot more of
the money
when you sign up on our website but that
is new member number four and if we get
ten I'll open up the phone lines okay
just saw Bob oh so says David watched
the Joker Joaquin Phoenix
trailer okay I mean let's check it out
right now
the Joker trailer people have been
talking to me about this I don't know
what the big deal is I don't know how is
playing the Joker I don't know anything
about I guess Joaquin Phoenix is that's
what this person is telling me let's
take a look Arthur does it help have
someone to talk to
[Music]
my mother always tells me to smile and
put on a happy face
she told me I had a purpose to bring
laughter and joy to the world
[Music]
is it just me I said like I said getting
crazier out there
though your heart is aching smile even
though it's breaking when there are in
the sky all right I think I've seen
enough this is a movie that I want to
see this is definitely a movie that I
want to see III knew nothing about this
because I'm so disconnected from a lot
of pop culture stuff but Joaquin Phoenix
is awesome
I hate superhero movies except the
Batman universe when my family this is
an interesting story some of you might
like and some of you might hate don't
cancel your memberships over the story
when my family moved to the United
States in 1989 I knew two words of
English stop and blue this is real and
when we got settled and went to a store
I guess an electronic store seems we
were to even say it now that you just
get everything on Amazon went to an
electronic store and got a little 20
inch television which I actually had up
until two years ago in my basement
finally got rid of it all
and a VCR tape player we got to go to
Blockbuster which also is you know I
think we all know what I'm talking about
here and I got to pick out a movie and
the movie I picked was Batman with Jack
Nicholson and Michael Keaton is this
story even possible is that movie from
1989 imagine if the movies from like 93
and I've completely fabricated this
memory anyway and as I recall Batman
with Jack Nicholson and Michael Keaton
accelerated my English vocabulary
significantly and this looks really good
so I'm glad glad you mentioned it okay
thank you to Caitlyn Stamper unclear if
she's related to Doug Stamper Caitlyn
Stamper is a new member at david
pakman.com slash membership new member
number five of the evening and joseph
Dizzy's oh okay
all right so I see what's going on so
Joshua Stoltenberg is not the caller
from 4 to 5 now joseph din Z's has
signed up I guess I'm getting these
notifications on a delay which a couple
people have suggested to me what's going
on
is new member number six of the evening
which gets 60% of the way to our target
of 10 a RIE Suslov says is there a mrs.
pacman yes
I've mentioned her before although she's
not miss pac-man because because we're
not married out there is a new member on
YouTube that is new member number seven
which gets a 70% of the way there Jack
me--off is sending a $2 super chat like
how I did that there I'm not Bill
O'Reilly Jack me--off is sending a $2
super chat Khalil Ahmadi sends a 50
Danish kroner super chat isn't it like
half YouTube takes per donation no
though no YouTube takes 30% is what is
my understanding Jimmy from Philly sends
a $2 super Chad why are you so afraid of
being held accountable I've seen no
evidence to suggest that that's the case
Jimmy I wonder if Jimmy's leaving
voicemails again like a crazed guy he uh
we we found out Jimmy drinks a lot on
the show last week and he left a
voicemail let's see one two how many did
he leave one two three four five six
Jimmy has left six voicemails since my
last live stream and in at least one of
them he indicated that he was drinking
his 11.5% beer Karen honey Nia Karen
honey Nia Orhan Anya is new member
number 8 of the evening which gets us
80% of the way there we might be taking
a lot of phone calls tonight because
memberships are coming in very very
quickly once again I'll remind you ten
new members I open up the phone lines
fifteen new members
I will likely do a stream from the
progressive media meeting of the minds
that is set to take place in Las Vegas
starting tomorrow so get those
memberships in and there there are just
some stunning stunning stunning
discounts available and I wonder if I
could even show you here you just see
something want to make sure that I can
get this display
correctly because there I'm seeing some
messages with confusion yeah let me see
if I can do this okay so this is the
this is the website okay any one of
these memberships you can select and
apply the coupon code this is twenty
twenty two but there is a particular
membership with an even more stunning
membership special available it requires
you to switch to yearly okay this is the
key thing and I'm seeing messages in the
chat from people saying that save thirty
five isn't working you've got to switch
to yearly and you can't slide up to
these other memberships okay it only
works with the sixty dollar membership
you hit sign up and I'm gonna do this
now let's say my name is oh I don't know
let's say my name is Donald Trump okay
and my email is you know real hair at
whoa that was weird
hitting the add sign change the shot
real hair at you know Trump dot org or
whatever it doesn't even matter anyway
the point is this is where you type in
the coupon code and if you type in save
thirty five and as I press buttons
things are just getting completely crazy
you will see that it has changed as my
zoom goes completely bonkers to twenty
five dollars a year and you're able to
keep that coupon code for as long as you
want that experiment did not work
particularly well but in any case it
that's how it works and two more and we
will do live calls seven more and I will
do a stream from Las Vegas okay
let's get back to the Super chats Zenda
crust says do obsessive stalkers like
Jimmy concern you you know they do to
some degree but we do have regular
contact with the FBI and other law
enforcement agencies and the stuff we
identify is really serious like let me
give you an example Jimmy left me six
voicemails since the last live stream
and we're kind of joking around about it
and sometimes I'll talk to Jimmy on the
phone there is someone else I'm not
mentioning who has left one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven twelve
13 14 15 15 voicemails in the last two
days I'm not mentioning them because
there's a serious concern and those are
forwarded to it to law enforcement so
that's a little story for you there Joe
Chill erson sends a 17 Danish Kroners
super check do you like the ending of
house of cards I don't you know there
are very few TV series where I find the
ending satisfying now I don't have to
like it it doesn't have to be a
feel-good ending but it has to be
satisfying in some way that is kind of
like relevant to the story the Breaking
Bad ending I found very very well done
and satisfying and logical in a way and
while you know I the thing about the
house of cards ending is that after
Kevin Spacey's troubles legal trouble
started there was sort of an alteration
to the trajectory of the show made I
don't think that the way they ended the
show is the way that they planned to end
the show but I still found it relatively
ok on the basis of what what did and
didn't make sense internally based on
the characters and whatnot it wasn't my
favorite ending but I do think that it
was it was logical in a way Jane a
described a dictatorship how does this
administration differ well Donald Trump
has authoritarian tendencies but it is
not a dictatorship because we still have
checks and balances increasingly frayed
and not well-functioning checks and
balances but we still have them so it's
just a we don't have a dictatorship we
have a president who would love to have
one that's that's for sure Jimmy from
Philly says I'm blocked on the regular
chat wait a censer you know I haven't
blocked you Jimmy I'm wondering it oh
well let's see people Wow right now I'm
looking at the chat and it is chaos way
to get yourself blocked Jimmy let me see
what he said What did he say uh oh boy
our we've got a we have a trigger-happy
moderator who said I'm trying to see
here let me see if I can find the
message that got Jimmy banned maybe I
can over
ride it if I have a disagreement but I
would not dream of disagreeing with a
moderator let's see here Jimmy from
Philly oh no Jimmy you're not banned
you've just been timed out I I think
that that's reasonable Jimmy I think
when Jimmy drinks he just gets out of
control I don't know that we need to go
immediately to a ban unless he really
starts you know slurring people
slandering people
it's just crazy what's happening here
but he's in that timeout okay and his
paid message did get read so that's
that's I think that's an appropriate
course of action okay Jason Flaherty is
a new david pakman show member thank you
will from the 503 area code is a new
david pakman show member I will make a
note of area code 503 which I believe is
Denver Austin Allen is a new member that
is new member number 11 of the evening
Constance Carter is a new member that's
new member number 12 of the evening and
Nicholas Hudson is new member number 13
of the evening thank you so much to all
of you we are going to open up the phone
lines momentarily only two people have
signed up with a with an area code and
they're going to be the first two people
that I take calls from so there are many
opportunities to get on the phones and
if you include your area code when you
sign up as either in the first or last
name field put in your full name but
also just add your area code somewhere I
will go to you first and the next person
to do that can get on the phone with me
third would be third in line so I am
going to open the phone lines at 6 1 7 8
3 0 47 50 I will let people start to
call in and I think will be there's a
lot people are shot out of cannons
tonight so I think it's going to be a
really great thing to take some phone
calls again the number is 6 1 7 8 3 0 47
50 and as people call in I will take a
couple of other super chats here are
Isis love says is there a pacman jr.
there is not and being culturally Jewish
we tend not to do the jr. thing you only
name people after ancestors who are no
longer alive so there will never be a
pacman jr. there could only be
people with other names max oak Smith
says please stream on Twitch I've
thought about starting to do stuff on
Twitch but I have to admit I don't
really know what the point would be
because I've we have such a much larger
audience on YouTube that I don't know if
there's a benefit to starting from
scratch on twitch but manat ruling it
out it's something I would consider
doing Jack me--off
sends a $2.00 super chat thank you very
much bhisma's says David how do you call
BS on a candidate who has flipped their
position on an issue for political gain
versus a candidate who has truly evolved
there's no rule I've talked about this
before what's the difference between
flip-flopping and evolving on your
opinion there is no sort of set of
parameters that I could tell you you
really just have to analyze it on a on a
case-by-case basis and there's a little
bit of you know it when you see it type
of thing
and there's also circumstances I mean
listen I've mentioned this before Dave
Rubin claims to have had a political
awakening where he went from basically
agreeing with Bernie Sanders on
everything that's a direct quote to
being a conservative right and I think
he was like 38 or 39 years old when it
happened I don't know how that's
possible I don't know how that's
possible I mean I've had modifications
to my political views since I became an
adult but I really seems to me that the
older you are the more sort of
established you are in knowing yourself
and having such a drastic political
evolution on on so many issues at that
point in life seems difficult you know
evolving on gay marriage as Tulsi
Gabbard says she has okay maybe she did
maybe she didn't I don't really know
that but it's possible evolving on
taxation policy what I get it but you've
really got to just look at these cases
individually okay I'm about to take
phone calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 now
interestingly
one of the people who signed up and gave
me their area code because they want to
call in are currently on hold I have
plenty of people on hold but not those
people so I'm gonna give it just another
minute or two in case of four to five or
five oh three want to call in and if you
want to call in and get right on become
a new member and include your area code
in the first or last name field six one
seven eight three zero
4750 is the number the lines are open a
couple of other super chats Steve Lonnie
with a dollar
Eddie Lopez with five bucks and Arai
Suslov says orange you glad this isn't
another pac-man joke I really am I
really am because it would be disturbing
for there to be another pac-man joke
okay let's go to where do we want to go
let's go oh let me get my notes set up
we have a I always take notes about the
caller's and then enter those notes into
our call system so when they call back
in I can see what it is that's going on
let's go to Joseph we last heard from
Joseph in January what's going on Joseph
doing really good how about you
hey good yeah so um I wanted to talk to
you about like about a voting system so
what'd you guys talk about what'd you
call it multi choice voting and whatnot
like that ranked choice voting yeah um
I'd like to thank suggest something that
maybe you haven't heard of I get this
kind of question if you have heard of it
okay have you heard of mixed-member
proportional representation before I
have I have although I don't think I've
studied it enough to be able to get all
the pros and cons and contrast to some
of these other systems but I have a
video is that a system you like I think
it's a really great system if we're
talking about congressional like
legislative elections I'm open to the
idea of ranked choice for executive
positions okay
or or especially for like inside the
Democratic Party like I thinking that
I'm I'm I'm a student member in the
Democratic Party and we're really
pushing to get ranked choice because I
think it's just a better way to choose
the candidate insider like the party
yeah um but basically what mixed member
proportional representation is
if there's functionally there's two
votes you both your first vote is based
on like okay what what who do you want
your representative in your district to
be and it's just a simple majority okay
then you have a second vote which is
what is your preferred party so what
then so what that happens is that on
let's just saying you have a
gerrymandered state and then even though
5050 let's say 50% of people favor the
democratic party or 50% of people favor
the republican party look they can be
massively gerrymandered to a point where
like the Republicans control 80% of the
seats sure on what the mix member does
of what the mmm on PR does is that in
with that second coat it takes into
recognition like Oh half the half the
state wants this one party half the
state want to this party so they add
at-large seats they give out large seats
to put onto a party and and to balance
out the state so it actually reflects
the electorate like
what got it got it got it so in other
words if the congressional elections saw
one party hold 80% of the seats but in
that second vote 50 percent of the
state's population for example wanted
the other party there would be enough
at-large seats added such that each
party would end up with 50 percent of
the seats is that roughly what you're
saying yeah yeah that's about it it's
like for example I'm from Germany
yeah and I'm from the state of Bavaria
and in Bavaria there's a regionalist
party and they win every single district
oh you wouldn't it's the CSU they want
every single one and even if you had a
rank choice they would still win every
single district there wouldn't be any
like there wouldn't be any third parties
so the so the proportional
representation basically all these out
large seats counterbalance let's like
they give all the sort of that voting
influence to all the other parties like
the SDP and AFD even though ft is
terrible but stuff like that so it's
actually it's actually good way so you
get third parties in and to Congress and
so on and so forth very inviting
um Joseph I am going to be marking you
as a very very good caller your
connection was pristine you got right to
the point you brought up something that
I am now going to research and read
about so I I give you a ten out of ten
okay thank you very much very good and
very polite in accepting the ten out of
ten I like it okay Joseph originally
from Germany okay let's go oh I have a
few super chats
I hate apricots says who do you think
will replace the DHS secretary Ken
Cuccinelli former Virginia AG is being
floated he's most well-known for wanting
to ban oral sex so that is who I heard
is being suggested amazing shooter says
what's your favorite NBA team the Boston
Celtics and although you know I have a
friend who works for the Wizards so I
kind of have to like them a little bit
although you know Mohammed Pope has
sense a 99 cent super chat and Jane
womanpower says was gonna suggest Jimmy
from Philly be banned but I think he
will benefit from your show he gets
therapy and education here yeah he's
holding and I'd consider going to him
but I do try to avoid going to the same
people super frequently Daniel J Pierce
is a new member that is number 14 for
the evening and Blaine shake is also a
member that is number 15 for the evening
very very exciting
okay let's go next to let's go to
someone new let's go to the eight to
eight area code who's calling today from
the eight to eight area code eight to
eight I can kind of hear you in the
background do you know your area code I
hear a kid is that it someone spanking
their kid eight to eight you're on the
air and if you're hitting your kid
please stop we can hear you oh and
they're gone okay I will make a note
possibly hitting child
all right that is a very very low ranked
call I can assure you okay let's go next
to the two one four area code caller
from two one four who's there hello yes
um I'm its ARMA also known as the
rational voice okay I have a question
about Johann Omar okay so you claim that
the way she acted was anti-semitic but
when did I claim that isn't it come
isn't it completely open to
interpretation
when did I claim that well you implied
it in your video pretty clearly no I say
in the video you claimed her statements
were anti-semitic I did not I encourage
you to find any stuff any video of me
saying that her statements were
anti-semitic I could recall the video it
got mass dislike it was called Johanna
Omar being anti-semitic or something
like that and it was not it was not
called that
so you so far you've misstated in two
different ways what I said and misstated
the title of the video okay what would
that a little video that I don't
remember but I made it very very clear
in the video it was months ago it's
interesting that you'd think you would
have looked at it before calling in I
made very clear that I was not saying
she is anti-semitic or that the
statements are anti-semitic I pointed
out that the statements do relate to a
known anti-semitic trope and I've since
clarified every time someone calls in I
say you're misquoting me I didn't say
she's anti-semitic I didn't say the
comments are anti-semitic so how would
you suggest that it's a anti-semetic
trope well it's not how would I suggest
it I mean we covered it on today's
program not in the context of villain
Omar the idea of dual loyalty among Jews
is a common anti-semitic trope I'm not
saying she's anti-semitic I'm not saying
the comment is inherently anti-semitic
it was just an observation but you
you're quoting something I just never
said she was you talk about dual loyalty
between sovereign countries
okay now I don't know what you're what
you're referring to all right
thanks anyway check the video all right
check the video thank you okay let's go
next to UM where else do we want to go
mm-hmm let's go to Brendan from
Pennsylvania Brendan from Pennsylvania
what's going on hey David how you doing
I'm good I just wanted to I called
earlier in the past and I was kind of on
the subject of trade school and like
labor jobs in the future and I watched
the Andrew yang interview and I really
thought I was interesting I appreciated
you like playing everything with UVI and
asking him specific questions about that
but he brought up the increasing number
of people that are gonna be needed in
the United States in the labor force and
I just wanted to again ask like what
would be the best options like that are
either currently available or other
things but the government could be doing
more to you know it uh solicit people to
be going into those jobs sorry - you're
saying what could the government do to
incentivize people to do what to go into
trade schools and learn those crafts oh
that's right now we have like a really
big college incentive like you and
wranglers bringing up yeah but remember
most people still aren't going to
college so even though there there are
incentives most people still are not
going to college it seems that maybe
what you're saying is not so much that
people going to college shouldn't
necessarily instead go to trade school
but maybe people that aren't doing
anything after high school should be
going to trade school is that possible
yeah yeah I mean I think that looking at
in the same way that we incentivize and
and maybe this exists at the state level
and I don't know enough about it and if
that's the case then I look forward to
being corrected in the same way that
there are programs where if you become a
doctor and then work for five years or
ten years in underprivileged underserved
areas you can have your student loan
debt forgiven there should be similar
programs that incentivize people to be
going
to certain trades that are needed I
think there's a whole bunch of different
ways that it could be set up but it
could be hugely advantageous both for
people and for the industries that need
more well-trained workers yeah it's
interesting I mean I decided to go to
college but my friends from back home
they entered like labor positions I
never even considered like I didn't have
any education in thinking about even how
I mean their plans are actually to start
there no business is based off of the
straits that they're learning which is
something that I've never even had
considered okay Brendan listen your
audio is trailing off and getting lower
and lower so I appreciate the phone call
a point taken and I appreciate you
bringing it up but I'm gonna let you go
for the time being and look forward to
hearing you again hearing from you again
let me say hello to new member number 16
of the evening Sam Dean Sam Dean is a
new member taking advantage of the
coupon code save 35 a horror fan for
life says who was best elegant Elliot
often Eric the actor or Riley Martin
Frank the dwarf also great show hashtag
Bernie hashtag mentally ill in chief
must go so this is a quite a Howard
Stern Show question you know I was never
a big fan of Frank the dwarf and I'm
just using the name that he had I'm not
suggesting that it's a name I would give
to anyone or that it's a an appropriate
name for anybody i but he was a little
bit very early in my listening to Howard
Stern elegant Elliott often was one of
the most compelling figures on the
Howard Stern Show ever Eric the actor a
completely different character and and
also endlessly interesting and I found
Riley Martin's alien nonsense just so
compelling it is really hard for me to
say I think maybe just for nostalgia I
would rank elegant Elliott often first
maybe then Eric the actor and then Riley
Martin although it's really really tough
wreck soul is asking whether I have any
new recipes oh let me think do I have
any new recipes I've got like a sort of
one sheet salmon thing that I've been
doing
you get that potato medley of all
different colored small potatoes and you
toss them in salt pepper olive oil and
throw it in the oven on a sheet pan for
like 25 minutes or something like that
and in the meantime you make a marinade
do people care about this I'm just I'm
asking I'm doing what people are asking
for you make a marinade for I prefer
salmon although you could pick your fish
and the marinade is made of soy sauce
lemon minced garlic minced ginger and I
think some honey and you reserve about a
third of it for later put 3/4 of it in a
bag with your pieces of salmon and then
after the potatoes are basically cooked
on that same sheet pan you move the
potatoes out of the way put a bunch of
green beans on salt and pepper them and
then you put the salmon in the middle i
recommend cooking to where it comes out
at a hundred and thirty degrees it'll
keep climbing to about 135 and it'll be
just past medium which i think is
perfect and then you just pour the rest
of the sauce on the green beans and on
the salmon and you've got yourself
you've got yourself dinner there that's
a new one that i it's been one of my
go-to is i'm doing it once a week or
isis love in a super chat says love the
show thank you for it ok let me check
whether any of our new member let's see
area code four to five or 503 yeah i'm
not seeing the people that would have
first caller privileges holding on here
but let's go to let's go to the hmm the
eight to eight person is back no it's a
different eight to eight person let's go
to eight to eight again different eight
to eight than before hey hey who's this
hey this is nick out there from this
Asheville North Carolina how you doing
hey Nick hi how are you sorry about that
that was crazy that was yeah I wasn't on
the line yet I'm so sorry I'm hearing
myself on a delay oh it looks like you
fixed it yeah go ahead
yeah so I'm so sorry about that whole
incident because I was not in the phone
chat yet anyway
it's a minus 0.5 on whatever caller
score you're about to get because of
that little mishap okay all right thank
you all right so I'm gonna walk outside
now so I'm gonna make sure the
connection is good all right so I guess
the question I want to ask you I don't
know how to frame this because it has to
do with Stephen Miller and besides we
can always go back to his path and his
bows out there and understand who he is
as a person and what he believes and
what not but what do you believe because
nobody talks about this to me what I
deem that my evidence
what do you believe his influence is on
Donald Trump from a day-to-day basis on
not just the policies he makes but just
the reactions we see you know
spontaneous reactions we see from Donald
Trump I think I think you're bringing up
something that's important which is to
the extent that Donald Trump is
commenting on stuff on a day to day
basis I often joke around you know a lot
of what Trump says is just what someone
told him five minutes before the camera
was turned on I think that a lot of
those five minutes before the camera
turns on hints are coming from Stephen
Miller so I think Trump's day-to-day
vocabulary and rhetoric is significantly
influenced by Miller nice I mean you
keep it elaborating if you want to
that's really I just think this and
something has not brought up right right
I don't know story because there's
there's no you can't point to it so
that's what I guess what I was saying
nobody talks about because of everything
I think even Trump can't necessarily
point to how his worldview his sort of
perspective on how things work is
influenced by the people around him like
Stephen Miller because Trump's ego won't
allow him to believe that anyone is
really influencing him so do you believe
it was a grooming process with Stephen
Miller's like or could be like it I mean
of course somebody's an aide would have
something okay not as specific yeah I
mean I the question that's always been
bothering me for the last well I just
never heard anybody speak um but thinks
you're taking about my call David Miller
I love the show I'll just tell you you
got a half a point deduction for the
echo
and a half worker in half appointed
deduction for the interrupted signal but
because you remember you're at plus
twenty so you're basically the best
caller ever appreciates your burger all
right very good very very high score for
Nick Hudson they're very exciting okay
let's go where are we going next okay
listen I'm gonna do this once do we want
to hear from Jimmy from Philly or don't
we and Jimmy I he gets you know he
doesn't have a right to be on all the
time but I see he's been he's now been
holding longer than anybody else do we
want to hear from from Jimmy from Philly
I'll just look at what people say in the
chat yes yes yes yes yes no yes one more
four no yes yes yes no yes no no yes yes
yes yes I think the yeses have it so
let's just check in with him briefly we
won't let him get out of control if he
starts with AD homonyms we will pull him
off Jimmy what do you have for me today
David yeah one of the things says I held
you in high regard for ya was that you
didn't censor me and I can prove this
and super chat to the heart bear certain
phone conversations with him and yet
your moderator in the chat tonight right
yeah you know here's the progressive
thing like like not admit to what you're
doing just change the word and say time
Dale Jimmy I don't know what on earth
you're I know I'm upset David okay I
know that I would you why would you do
this to me
what did i do again what do you mean
what'd you do it got me timed down you
couldn't find it because there wasn't
one well there's nobody then sold at me
but you know Jimmy let's back off a
little bit here hold on there's no way
I'm someone out unless they've said
something so the idea that there's no
message that got you timed out you can
only time someone out on on a message so
you said something no I'm saying timed
out is the same as censorship David
that's not complete the issue here no I
clearly defined
there was something about the you have
no I told somebody to blow me that
insulted me I think that's the one that
probably got designing David I've never
directly disrespecting you
how many 11.5% ORS have you had tonight
I'm on the force one nail really very
good that's like nine normal beers all
right Jamie very good great to hear from
you alright let's see what we have going
on the chat is just titillated here by
what's going on okay let me let me just
go to a couple of the super chats that
are here what time is it oh it's eight
o'clock okay so I don't have unlimited
time left here
Sabrina Zafar says what are your
favorite bands and musicians what do you
listen to daily you know I could name a
whole bunch of different American bands
and musicians but that's boring I'll
tell you about some of the stuff that's
less common that I'm listening to it's a
lot of Argentinian bands Mexican bands
Colombian bands some good Argentinian
bands I recommend you check out
argentinian reggae band los médicos
excellent excellent band argentinian ska
band go south in thickest ditka then
this awesome band another argentinian i
guess it's almost like scoffs slash
reggae justify us was Cadillacs what
else I don't know those are a couple
let's see here I hate apricots says if
Trump invited you to the White House
would you go sure
adjacent round twelve says what do you
think will happen to Dhaka I'm scared
I I really think that there's going to
be that daca recipients are going to be
okay
I I do think that they're going to be
okay one way or the other and black way
54 says you're Pakman spit in straight
facts tell these miss quotes they don't
want the smoke from the pack gert gang
gang extraordinarily eloquent and I
couldn't couldn't say it any better
myself okay
Jimmy I see you're back on I'm not going
to you again Jimmy I just don't don't
even don't even bother it's not it's not
happening today okay 704 area code who's
calling today from 704 I wait
all right who said okay we originally
college from the eight to eight number
but we were pulling a Jimmy at a few too
many to drink before we call it that we
got nervous
what's it know Oh Oh like I see what
you're saying Jimmy the guy I just spoke
to you right yeah what's your name
my name is Amber I don't listen to you
my boyfriend does and he's constantly
trying to get me to listen to your
podcast and stuff okay so he's a good
guy
yeah I wanted you to convince me on why
I should listen to your podcast oh I
don't know I should I mean it's not for
everybody listen if you're looking for
me to strong-arm you which I would never
of course do to anybody in the physical
sense but speaking metaphorically
maybe the podcast isn't for you what I
would tell you is you might get a lot
out of the podcast the podcast
relationship is a much more intimate
relationship shall I say you know when
we talk to advertisers one of the things
we've noticed is that the random YouTube
viewer is far less connected to the show
in a visceral and intimate way compared
to someone who's actually sitting there
and listening in their headphones are on
speakers for an hour straight to the
podcast so what I would tell you is if
you're an open-minded person if your
boyfriend is generally speaking a good
guy who has your best interest in mind
maybe he's on to something give a couple
episodes a try if it's not for you no
hard feelings that's I was like really
expecting you to I really try and
convince me you know I like being like
oh listen I don't want people here under
protest right I mean I would say check
it out it might be a good podcast for
you if it's not what am I going to say
but I think it would be premature to say
no podcast before you've even listened
to it you know yeah yeah no I can
respect that um thank you very much I
will give your podcast a few lessons and
see how it goes also no children were
busy in good yeah I'm an update so I had
flagged that phone number as
children being beaten but I am going to
update that okay thank you no one was
the envy and we just we didn't expect
the call to get picked so when it was
we're like Oh got it an interesting
different phone it looks like yeah we
thought that maybe the eight to eight
was plot and I won't block it now okay
and thank you very much because I
wouldn't want to ruin the experience for
Joshua but thank you okay thank you very
much appreciate the phone call okay
let's go to the four one two area code
for one two I associated as a very
working-class area code because I
believe it's Pittsburgh is that right
hey there's me yes it is
wow I would not expect a gig picked uh
uh I love your go man thank you for
doing let's do thank you
who's this what's your name my name is
Matt and my question is my question is
uh I know you mentioned Sweden have no
minimum wage because of their strong
trade you didn't present right how do
you think do you think that this could
work in the United States as well I mean
listen if we had if the relationship
between corporations and the government
and the people completely changed and
became like that of Sweden if trade
unions gained the power and clout that
they have in Sweden then sure it could
work but so many things would have to
change for that to be the case in the
United States were not uh not heading in
that direction I can tell you that yeah
thank you um I have another quick
question if you'll turn sorry you
recently got into an disagreement with
my Tracy on Twitter with who do who was
it with
Michael Tracy oh okay
uh what do you think about his recent
victory lap on Twitter he's doing about
the old Trump Russia debate what what
see - I don't
all I know is this guy named Michael
Tracy appeared on with Sam cedar last
week and then he started picking on me
on Twitter and I think I sent him one or
two responses but I don't know who he is
or what he's doing what is he doing on
Twitter uh he's doing a major victory
lap right now because apparently he was
right about the whole Russia Trump
collusion the whole time
Oh being kind of a smug good dick about
it
all power to him hope he has a lot of
followers and is having a good time I
don't know what else to tell you
I hope hope he's enjoying it all right
Thank You Man okay I appreciate the
phone call thank you very much okay a
couple of other super chats here Sam
Dean says have you seen that Trump might
be going to the UK and getting a full
carriage procession in June any thoughts
on the use of such a visit Cheers no I
didn't hear that
and I'm gonna have to I'm gonna have to
check that out that would be it's what
he wants but I'll let you know once I
read about it
Harry Heng says what are your thoughts
on Ben Shapiro and Andrew Yang's
conversation if not when I haven't seen
it haven't seen it but I will try to
check it out maybe tomorrow
I hate apricots says do you fear
reprisal by big seltzer and Kyle's legs
I don't I I have no concern whatsoever
about such such a reprisal let's go to
the nine one seven area code who's
calling today from nine one seven eight
seven one nine seven one Tom can you
hear me I can sort of but you're kind of
cutting in and out okay how's that
better that is better who's this my name
is Tom I'm going in from Washington and
I got turned on to your show when you
did your interview with Andrew yang okay
so I was a really big fan of sort of the
way you interviewed him wasn't softball
but was also usable but my question for
you is actually revolving around
dialogue on kind of what could
considered controversial topics okay so
I'm not sure how to encourage
conversations I think those sort of went
out there like say like the wage gap
right so it's harder to start a
conversation on wage gap because some
people are like oh it's a myth other
people like oh it's definitely
real right and then if you just say that
you're critical like you're like okay
well you know I was there is if there is
an issue I'd like to help but I need I
would like you to show me the issue and
then that becomes like oh you're part of
the problem like I don't take these
issues on blind faith that you know
you're a part of Rome that's not really
where I want to come from I just want to
make sure that you know hey let's let's
look at the data yeah I think so this is
something it's interesting you mentioned
the weight that the gender wage gap
issue because I mistakenly delved into a
discussion on a Facebook friends profile
over the weekend about this and I tried
to point out that some of the numbers
that the person had posted weren't
accurate that we've studied this pretty
significantly and 77 cents on the dollar
it's just wrong and that I'm on their
side I want there to be gender pay
equality for the same work between men
and women but that we've got to start
with the right numbers if we want to
seriously have the conversation and I
was totally shut down and I was told
that I was using the wrong language and
tone and that the real numbers aren't so
important as the fact that the wage gap
exists which I disagree with I mean the
point if the wage gap is ten cents on
the dollar versus ninety cents on the
dollar the numbers make a difference
that's a very different situation so my
advice is try to start with questions
okay say oh I'm really that sounds
really serious that sounds like a
serious problem how did you learn that
this was a problem and start asking
those probing polite but sort of as
neutral as possible questions to try to
get the person to recognize where they
do and don't have the required
information to make the call and that
that's the best thing none of these
things are super effective but that's
worked relatively well for me okay I
want trying to get more questions
because they appreciate your time but
thanks for taking my call
okay thanks really appreciate it great
to hear from you horror fan for life
sent to $5 super chat saying me and my
girlfriend we're watching a documentary
on Netflix about Psychopaths Trump
aligned with multiple traits any thought
that he could just be a psychopath I
don't think so I think there's a number
of different possible conditions Donald
Trump may have
I don't think psychopathy is one of them
but I'm not an expert and we would
really have to talk to someone who is to
find out more about that okay I've got
to get packed for my very very long
flight across the country tomorrow so
that does it for today I will try to
stream from Las Vegas later this week
thanks to everybody who called in signed
up sent super chats chatted in the
regular chat signed up on patreon and
became YouTube members it's all very
much appreciated and I will talk to you
again very soon